sieben jahre alt und trotzdem sind sie
ist die das geld in der familie
verdienen nicht ihre eltern und zwar auf
youtube kinder influenza haben mitunter
so viele follower können ihre
erwachsenen kollegen einfach nur staunen
und wenn man dann auch noch die werbung
richtig platziert dann kann man damit
richtig geld verdienen das heißt also
ein gutes geschäft auch für die eltern
aber wie ist das eigentlich für die
kinder so in der öffentlichkeit zu
stehen
darum soll es heute gehen und wir wollen
außerdem auf die gefahren schauen bei
youtube für kinder
denn auf der plattform sind auch
pädophile unterwegs wenn ihr fragen habt
zum thema dann postet sie mir gerne hier
unten in die kommentare
wir schauen jetzt aber erstmal auf die
minderjährigen youtube stars kinder
youtube stars davon gibt es eine ganze
menge auch in deutschland mit zum
beispiel hier spricht man wirklich so
aus ihr kanal hat weit mehr als 700.000
zuschauer und dank dieses kanals haben
ihre eltern inzwischen sogar ihre jobs
ausgeben können also wir haben jetzt den
vorteil wir können von den youtube einen
enormen leben die minderjährige tochter
sorgt also für den unterhalt der
gesamten familie ist das doch ein hobby
oder ist das schon arbeit 2014 hat der
fahrer die zum ersten mal vor der kamera
gezeigt damals war sie fünf jahre alt
auch die 12 jährige emilie menzel aus
weißenfels in sachsen anhalt hat einen
kanal auf die emi gucken ihr mehr als
100.000 menschen zu gesät und die
übrigen schleim herstellt oder ihr
zeugnis sagt es macht mir halt spaß und
wenn ich halt zeit oder lust habe dann
mache ich das hat natürlich auch aber
wenn er zeit wirklich irgend etwas
wichtigeres kommt auch von wegen schule
oder so dann ist das natürlich wichtiger
zu hause bekommt emily viel
unterstützung liegt so oder so dinge bei
denen du sagst also das würde ich ihnen
nicht erlauben dass sie das macht
im schwimmbad den zum beispiel haben wir
auch schon gemacht
natürlich geht die kamera dann nehmen
wir die kleine kabine ist ganz klar
wissen öffentlicher ort und was wir sich
mehr auf der liege neben mir liegt es
halt meiner meinung nach dem echten
leben wie im internet so und deswegen
sehe ich da nie den grund irgendetwas zu
verbieten
es geht noch ein ganz anderes thema das
in diesem zusammenhang wichtig ist
nämlich kinderarbeit
kinderarbeit ist in deutschland
gesetzlich geregelt kinder die vor der
kamera arbeiten brauchen ein
arbeitserlaubnis in einem video sprechen
millys eltern über dieses thema und
sagen dass das jugendamt sehr viele
auflagen macht wir dürfen nicht im
kinderzimmer film wenn wir dürfen nicht
in der schule filmen wir dürfen nicht
beim arzt film in einem gartenhaus beim
schwimmen und der punkt tut besonders
weh
medis eltern fühlen sich in
wettbewerbs-nachteil und zu unrecht
stigmatisiert sie sagen wir halten uns
an die regeln
die anderen machen das aber nicht und
tatsächlich sagen experten die wenigsten
eltern der kinder die bei youtube vor
der kamera sind haben eine erlaubnis vom
jugendamt eingeholt für das was sie da
machen warum
naja weil potenzielle geld durch die
lappen geht und das muss man auch sagen
viele kinder präsentieren bei youtube
produkte machen werbung für verschiedene
dinge hinein wie es in ihr enthalten
wird mit einem stark es gibt zwei
grundsätzliche haltungen in der
medienpädagogik die einen sagen es ist
schon okay wenn kinder das machen man
muss sich aber an die hand nehmen sie
begleiten und andere sagen nein das ist
überhaupt nicht okay das schade den
kindern das sollten sie auf keinen fall
dürfen und darüber spreche ich jetzt mit
dem journalisten und youtube mirko
drotschmann den viele von euch
wahrscheinlich als mister wissen zu
kennen
heini co johanna nico was sind deine
meinung dazu ist das jetzt okay wenn
kinder so einem rampenlicht stehen
das ist eine ganz schwierige frage also
wenn man jetzt mal die un die definition
von kindern nimmt dann sind das ja alle
unter 18 jährigen und das sehe ich nicht
so eng also ich finde schon 16 17
jährige können durchaus youtube videos
drehen können die veröffentlichen sobald
sie wissen was sie da tun ich finde das
ist entscheidend
gerade so 10 11 jährige kinder können ja
noch gar nicht abschätzen was es
bedeutet sein gesicht ins netz zu
stellen und weltweit verfügbar zu sein
und ich finde da sollten die eltern
einen schon schützen und wenn dann auch
noch geld im spiel ist dann erst recht
gerade das thema kinderarbeit ist da ja
sehr wichtig und ich finde die eltern
spielen da die entscheidende rolle wenn
die eltern mit den kindern zusammen
entscheiden wir machen das jetzt und die
kinder da wirklich an die hand nehmen
und begleiten sowie bei emi die wir ja
in dem kleinen ausschnitt gerade
kennengelernt haben dann ist das in
meinen augen okay aber wirklich nur dann
und vor allem muss das spaß bleiben
sobald es zur pflicht wird und zu einer
lästigen arbeit dann ist es ganz ganz
schwierig
jetzt hast du da ja in einem feld
recherchiert auch intensiver
recherchiert wie ist denn dein eindruck
gerade bei diesen professionelleren
kinder influenza ist das wirklich
freiwillig oder spielt da doch schon der
druck auch eine rolle
naja bei mylady wir gesehen haben ist es
natürlich so die eltern haben ihren job
aufgegeben
das heißt sie sind abhängig davon dass
ihre tochter sozusagen performt und eine
gute leistung abliefert und geld ins
haus bringt und wenn die tochter jetzt
mal sagen würde auch ich habe vier
wochen dann keine lust so videos zu
drehen ich will lieber als ferienlager
gehen und wir die kamera nicht mitnehmen
ja dann sagen die eltern wahrscheinlich
nie du musst weil sonst haben wir kein
geld und das ist natürlich eine ganz
ganz schwierige situation
in deutschland ist das aber eine
ausnahme es gibt international kinder
influenza das ist viel heftiger als
paradebeispiel ist für mich nastia vom
kanal nach der russischsprachige kinder
influenza in die zig millionen klicks
zum teil 25 30 millionen klicks auf ihr
die definitiv keinen spaß bei dem hat
was sie da macht zumindest sieht man
hier das an wenn man sich das angebot
das ist kein normales kind mehr
sie haben jetzt gerade ein paar ton aus
hatte aber ich hoffe das problem ist
nicht so schlimm und wir behalten dich
hier bei uns hier kommen natürlich auch
schon die ersten kommentare rein und es
geht ja auch nicht nur um kinder die
jetzt wirklich ganz professionell alles
in friends arbeiten sondern auch
generell um kinder um 12 13 jährige die
einfach vielleicht auf den kleineren
kreis videos hochladen wollen
hier wird gefragt von der dient zum
beispiel bei youtube was persönlich
siehst du denn als größte gefahr für
kinder auf youtube ja also eine große
gefahr sehe ich darin dass die kinder
eben nicht so genau
die folgen dessen abschätzen können was
sie da machen dass sie da vielleicht
dinge erzählen die sie später bereuen
dass die dinge machen die sie später
bereuen dinge wegen denen sie vielleicht
sogar gemobbt werden das ist das eine
große probleme und die zweite große
gefahr dass man auch die kollegen von
follow me report sehr gut aufgezeigt in
einem spannenden video das die diese
woche veröffentlicht haben das ist jede
menge potenzielle sexualstraftäter gibt
die nur darauf warten dass kinder sich
im schwimmbad filmen meerjungfrauen
videos machen oder andere dinge und die
sich sowas anschauen und ich ja das zu
ganz bestimmten zwecken
benutzen und da wird einem ganz anders
wenn man sich das vorstellt youtube hat
darauf vor einiger zeit reagiert hat zum
beispiel die kommentare unter
entsprechenden videos deaktiviert weil
da verschiedene sexualstraftäter dann so
genannte time stamps angefertigt haben
sagt dem motto guck mal bei zwei minuten
15 da hat sie gerade ihren badeanzug an
aber trotzdem gibt es davon noch jede
menge zu sehen und das schreiben wir
gleich auf jeden fall noch intensiver
drüber hier sind noch weitere kommentare
und da zum beispiel der fragt dich ganz
persönlich würdest du denn dein kind vor
der kamera zeigen wenn er sieht dass
wollen würde ich habe eine tochter die
drei jahre alt also noch nicht unbedingt
im alter entgegen ich möchte jetzt geht
mir influenza werden aber natürlich
merke ich das schon dass da ein großes
interesse am fall dran ist wenn ich mir
einfach nur meinen namen bei google
eingeben schon der erste begriff der
immer wieder damit gesucht wird kind
leute wollen halt wissen wie das eigene
kind aussieht und das möchte ich nicht
zeigen also es gibt ein paar fotos bei
instagram wo man unsere tochter von
hinten sieht das finde ich okay aber das
gesicht auf gar keinen fall wenn sie
irgendwann mal in einem alter ist in dem
die sagte papa ich hab irgendwie lustig
da mal so videos zu drehen und das bei
youtube hochzuladen
dann würde ich mir erstmal ganz intensiv
darüber reden was das bedeuten kann
und dann können wir gerne gemeinsam
diese videos machen
allerdings wenn sie dann tatsächlich
veröffentlicht würden dann nur als nicht
gelistet das bedeutet also es können nur
leute diese videos sehen den link dazu
haben man kann sie nicht über die suche
finden also nur im bekanntenkreis
sozusagen kann dieses video dann
verteilt werden das schränkt dann den
zuschauer kreis zumindest ein bisschen
ein
und ich würde das auch erst ab einem
gewissen alter machen also nicht mit
zehn oder elf sondern er dann so
richtung 14 15 16
wenn unsere tochter eben schon absehen
kann was sie da macht und wozu das
führen kann
jetzt sind ja die kommentare ganz oft
auch das problem dass da einfach
beleidigungen drin stehen die ja so ein
kind auch sehr treffen können was
empfiehlst du da eltern also sagst du
auf jeden fall mitlesen oder sagt sogar
vielleicht vorsicht oder was empfiehlst
du ja vorsichtig ist das beste würde ich
sagen es gibt ja die möglichkeit dass
man kommentare erst dann veröffentlicht
wenn sie freigegeben sind und die beste
lösung wäre finde ich wenn eltern es so
einstellen dass sie die kommentare vorab
sehen und sie dann freigeben so dass die
kinder unter umständen beleidigungen und
andere dinge gar nicht mitbekommen
natürlich muss man kinder nicht in watte
packen aber kinder müssen auch nicht
sich dinge anhören
die einfach in psychische schaden
und da bin ich sind die eltern schon da
in der pflicht auch drauf zu gucken
generell sollten eltern diesen ganzen
prozess von der produktion bis zur
veröffentlichung von vorne bis hinten
begleiten und ihre kinder auch schützen
und im richtigen moment auch sagen stopp
so und jetzt nicht weiter hier kommt
gerade auch ein ganz spannender
kommentar bei youtube von kaya der passt
ganz gut dazu
ich lese mal kurz vor haben einen kanal
hat mal mit ihrer kleinen schwester ein
video gemacht und in den kommentaren
waren dann pädophile aussagen aufgrund
dessen hat der kanal eine kommentar
sperre für einen gewissen zeitraum
bekommen und das spricht schon ein
bisschen thema an was du ja gerade auch
schon angerissen hast nämlich gefahren
die es eben bei youtube für kinder
einfach gibt denn diese videos von
kindern die schauen sich nicht nur
andere kinder ein oder andere erwachsene
sondern unter den erwachsenen sind
durchaus auch pädophile ein youtube hat
darauf anfang des jahres genauer
hingewiesen und daraufhin hat auch
youtube ein bisschen was verändert aber
die recherche unserer reporterin zeigen
das löst eben nicht das ganze problem
bringt wird anscheinend immer wieder
aufgefordert sich kleidung anzuziehen
wie man hier im video verfolgen kann
tut sie das am ende auch ende 2017 habe
ich eigentlich nur nach musikvideos auf
youtube gesucht und wir wurden videos
von kindern vorgeschlagen ich habe auf
eins drauf geklickt und wir wurden
daraufhin immer weitere videos von
kindern ausgespielt die teilweise auch
sehr knapp bekleidet das nackt in den
videos zu sehen waren aufwendig war
damals dass diese videos unglaublich
viele fonds hatten anfang 2009 10
hat mit watson dann mit einem video
publik gemacht dass der youtube
algorithmus wenn man einmal so ein
kinder video angeklickt hat immer
weitere dieser videos vorschlägt youtube
hat daraufhin dann versprochen den
algorithmus zu ändern da das ja auch für
bibliophile user sonst sehr interessant
ist ich habe mich dann gefragt ob diese
versprechungen von youtube in der
realität auch wirklich umgesetzt werden
und ob sie kinder am ende auch wirklich
schützen
deswegen habe ich dann angefangen
intensiv zu dem thema zu recherchieren
dabei bin ich dann auch auf einen live
stream eines deutschen mädchens gestoßen
werden einer playlist war
sie wurde von usern animiert sich die
füße mit rasierschaum einzureiben immer
wieder die füße in die kamera zu zeigen
man hat ihr geschrieben sie solle sich
doch knappe klamotten anziehen und dann
in gymnastik machen
als erstes wollen wir die eltern des
mädchens über unsere recherchen
informieren
wir haben die familie vorab per post
über unsere kommen informiert worum es
genau geht wollen wir aber lieber
persönlich besprechen
die tante des mädchens ist zu hause wir
sind den kannte genau das geht 68 sie
hat ja hauptsächlich eine zeitlang auf
youtube videos gelegt dass man keinen
spaß
zuviel zeit verschenken und gab es aber
irgendwas was sie komisch was ich kann
glaube ich nicht mehr erinnern aber
manchmal die zb einfach nur zwei dieser
blumen oder so lass mal die unsere
konkreten recherchen möchten wir der
tante alleine ohne das kind zeigen kann
irgendwie schon so vorstellen dass es
jetzt nicht wirklich kinder sind die
erfolgen sondern doch vielleicht ältere
menschen hast du das dann gesehen dass
wir und die augen auf das wir hier habe
ich noch nicht gesehen gehabt also hier
sieht man immer wieder dass sie auf
kommentare reagiert die dann wieder
verschwinden und in dem fall wird sie
immer wieder dazu aufgefordert sich die
füße ein zu schmieren mit rasierschaum
du dir also ich finde das echt krass bei
diesem mädchen gehen wir davon aus dass
das video nicht nur in der playlist
gelandet ist sondern dass es auch zu
kontaktaufnahmen kam und gegebenenfalls
auch zu sexuelle belästigung deswegen
zeigen wir dieses video jetzt auch einem
kriminalhauptkommissar also
strafrechtlich wird sicherlich ein
grenzfall sein ist einfach so aber das
verhalten denke mit der kinder auf dem
video der im video ist eigentlich
typisch man sieht sehr sehr gut wie die
kinder auf diese beeinflussung von außen
also der zuseher der kommentatoren
einfach reagieren und tatsächlich ohne
viel nachzudenken alles nach maß
youtube hat anfang des jahres zwar
reagiert das problem ist damit aber
leider nicht verschwunden sondern hat
sich in meinen augen verlagert darüber
sprechen wir mit mirko drotschmann miko
youtube hat ja jetzt schon reagiert und
hat diesen algorithmus geändert warum
hat das problem nicht komplett gelöst
und ich würde noch hinzufügen hier eine
frage von lady hat bei youtube die fragt
glaubst du denn überhaupt youtube kann
sowas verhindern
ich fürchte nein das ist das große
problem natürlich kann man gewisse
filter einstellen man kann dinge
verhindern aber gerade was live streams
angeht dafür hat man relativ wenig auf
den einfluss weil da kann alles mögliche
passieren und die besten filter schaffen
das glaube ich nicht schnell genug
zu reagieren das sieht man ja auch auf
anderen plattformen und deshalb ohne
youtube da jetzt zu sehr in schutz
nehmen zu wollen weiß ich ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht so genau wie man da noch
weiter vorgehen könnte was youtube wie
zum beispiel macht ist ein bankkonto zu
löschen wenn rauskommt das ist von
jemandem der sein alter falsch angegeben
hat und andere dinge man könnte
natürlich sagen bestimmte funktionen wie
live stream sind erst ab 18 verfügbar
aber dann macht sich halt ein
13-jähriger einfach an account der ihnen
als 19-jährigen ausgibt dann
funktioniert das wieder
also er letztendlich kann man youtube da
immer wieder austricksen und das ist ein
großes problem man könnte das
meldesystem ein bisschen optimieren und
dafür sorgen dass sobald jemand so etwas
sieht was nicht okay ist zum beispiel im
live stream
so eine art alarm button gedrückt werden
kann und dann sofort jemand händisch das
auch bei youtube erkennt und eingreifen
kann
da geht's ja wirklich um das schnelle
eingreifen und heute ist es so du
meldest was und dann kann es sein dass
in zwei drei tagen was passiert ist aber
unter umständen viel zu spät gerade bei
einem live stream
und ich glaube so ein alarm button der
dann bei einer tatsächlichen personen
rauskommt könnte ein richtiger schritt
in die richtung sein ok spannende idee
auf jeden fall
franzi fragt hier nach einem punkt den
hast du grad schon angerissen und zwar
nach dem alter sie die fragt sich warum
solche kanäle eigentlich überhaupt auf
youtube existieren dürfen weil sie ja
eigentlich erst ab 13 jahren und ich
glaube in deutschland sogar eigentlich
erst ab 16 erlaubt sind außer die eltern
machen eben mit wäre das eine
möglichkeit eben die kinder zu schützen
heja könnte eine möglichkeit sein aber
das lässt sich wirklich super einfach
umgehen
ich habe vor einiger zeit ein rechner
neu eingerichtet mit einem microsoft
konto und da musste man dann in alter
angeben und ich habe einfach mal zum
test ein alter angegeben dass mich als
kind hat erscheinen lassen und
tatsächlich musste man dann eine mail
adresse eines elternteils angeben
und dann musste dieser elternteil den
account erst freischalten
das wäre natürlich eine möglichkeit die
man auch bei youtube so wählen könnte
aber auch das lässt sich natürlich um
gehen dann macht man sich einfach eine
neue mail adresse und gibt die dann als
eltern adresse aus also auch das
schwierig also das ist eine sache die
wirklich nicht ganz einfach ist und
letztendlich kommt dass da auf die user
an aber auf andere zuschauer die dann
darauf reagieren müssen und und sowas
melden müssen damit youtube da
einschreiten kann
die große frage ist dann halt jetzt für
alle eltern wie kann ich mein kind
schützen
hier gibt es einen vorschlag von stefan
bei facebook der sagt kinder sollte man
nur in begleitung an youtube heranführen
ist das der richtige ansatz absolut
unbedingt also ich finde es ganz wichtig
dass eltern wissen was ihre kinder im
netz machen
ich kenne eltern deren kinder ihnen
freiwillig jeden abend ihr smartphone
geben und die eltern gucken dann dadurch
was hat das kind so am tag gemacht wo
war das unterwegs auf welchen seiten
geben hat es bei whatsapp geschrieben
das klingt jetzt ein bisschen nach
nachspiel und den nachschuss von uns
kann natürlich bei dem 17-jährigen oder
bei einer 16-jährigen er nicht machen
aber gerade bei kindern bei 12 13
jährigen glaube ich ist es schon möglich
und wenn dann vertrauensverhältnis
herrscht was der herrschen sollte
zwischen eltern und kindern
dann geht das schon ich nenne als
beispiel meine mutter die am hat sich
immer sehr interessiert für die musik
die ich früher gehört habt zum einen
weil sie es einfach spannend fand zum
anderen aber auch weil sie halt gucken
wollte ob ich kann nicht irgendwelche
bedenklichen dinge höre und ich habe das
überhaupt nicht so als nachspionieren
nach stücken empfunden sondern eher als
ehrliches interesse von ihr an dem was
nicht so mache an seiner lebenswelt und
wenn man als eltern teilt so herangeht
und sagt ja also ich möchte jetzt
einfach so mal wissen was du so machst
und kannst nur zeigen und das uns doch
da gemeinsam schauen dann ist das glaube
ich ein richtiger weg also das sollte
hand in hand gehen definitiv generell
die mediennutzung sollte nicht den
kindern alleine überlassen werden
da sind wir ja eigentlich schon
irgendwie mitten drin im thema
medienkompetenz jetzt ist aber leider so
dass viele eltern sagen was da auf
youtube passiert keine ahnung dass mein
kind sogar besser als ich siehst du da
nachholbedarf bei den eltern hier
schreibt zum beispiel auch ingrid bei
facebook kindergärten und schulen
sollten allgemein immer wieder mit den
eltern über das thema sprechen also
würdest du sagen da müsste es mehr
angebote geben in die richtung ja
unbedingt ich bin öfter auch bei
fortbildungen für eltern und die kommen
dann dasitzen und 20 30 eltern und ich
war zehn wissen was über youtube und die
stellen fragen und wir tauschen da so
ein bisschen uns ein bisschen aus und
ich finde solche angebote sollte es viel
viel häufiger geben
vielleicht auch im rahmen von
elternabende an schulen kindergärten
dass man externe einlädt die dann
darüber aufklären es gibt ganz tolle
medienpädagogen wie die digitalen helden
in hessen zum beispiel die genauso was
anbieten und davon sollte man dann auch
gebrauch machen das koste natürlich
immer ein bisschen geld aber ich finde
das ist schon wichtig natürlich muss man
dazu sagen man erreicht in der regel
diejenigen die schon ganz gut bescheid
wissen die die bescheid wissen sollten
die kommen meist es nicht zu so einem
elternabend und die lassen ihre kinder
dann das machen was sie wollen und das
ist ja dann problematisch aber
vielleicht haben sie ja uns jetzt gerade
hier zum beispiel in der zdf mediathek
oder bei twitter oder eben bei youtube
doch mit zugeschaut micro ganz
herzlichen dank dass du die zeit
gefunden hast heute und vielen dank für
deine einschätzung die infos und
dankeschön natürlich auch an euch das
waren echt ziemlich viele fragen und ich
hoffe wir konnten viele davon klären
die nächsten live stream hier den gibt
es am dienstag dann wieder um 20.30 und
wir würden uns sehr freuen wenn ihr
wieder dabei werde und wenn euch dieser
live-stream gefallen hat dann
interessiert euch vielleicht auch dieser
hier
da haben wir mit harald lesch über das
klima paket gesprochen
oder wer hier da ging es um den konflikt
im norden syriens oder ihr lasst uns
einfach hier ein abo da das wird uns
freuen
[Musik]